The joe rogan experience,
you took a long time off,
you took like six years off and then came back again in 2010 for one fight.
Yeah,
the,
I came back for that join you because I got put into jail.
I got put in prison and uh,
the,
you know,
it was funny because after I got out of prison,
it was on national TV.
It was in all the newspapers,
magazines,
funny.
Holly or I start fading out of the media.
All of a sudden I get arrested.
I'm like a hot thing in the media again.
You know what I say?
If there's a shocker.
So that's why the media,
but anyway,
you know,
I,
when I got out,
you know,
when I would go to bars and stuff,
he would say,
oh,
some people would say like,
I seen you on TV.
And I'm like,
fuck.
And I'm thinking to myself,
is that the one with me handcuff,
fuck in police?
Or was it an old god?
They hated that,
you know,
so I figured,
the only way to tell,
she'll,
um,
make it up to my fans.
I let them know that I'm back.
You know,
we,
we get drug to sit in Japan,
we get marijuana is a big thing now in Japan.
We get tested for marijuana.
If you have any marijuana in your blood in Japan,
you're not going to be able to fight it.
So what did you get arrested for?
Marijuana.
What happened?
Well,
I had a 16 grams in my car.
I had a great 20 joints I had,
we're going to have a little part in your pony and it was on the way down.
And they do a lot of inspections just randomly.
They walk around in Japan,
it's kind of unconstitutional where they don't need a reason to search you.
They'll come right up to your car and say,
I want a chicken your car.
And it's like I was stone and I had a,
I had a joint,
I mean a real short on the dashboard.
And you know when you're still in,
you think you're getting sneaky with you.
It's like so bad.
It's like,
ah,
what,
what role?
And I'm putting in my pocket and they're,
they're following me the whole time.
Like you sit in their pocket.
And I'm like,
so I pull up,
put my phone in the pocket,
pull it behind my flight.
I said nothing in my pocket.
This is behind your phone though.
Fuck.
So what,
how,
like what is it like,
is it like being caught with cocaine or heroin?
Drugs?
A drug in Japan.
Yeah.
So it doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter.
Yeah.
So I um,
I was facing some bad time,
you know,
because uh,
I was a famous figure and they wanted to make an example to me,
so,
wow.
What was the worst case scenario?
I think it was five years.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
So I was facing that.
Um,
it all depended on what came up in my house and my gym when he did the search
the next day.
Wow.
And what came up?
Nothing.
Nothing came on.
So that saved you?
Yeah.
Well I was kind of baffled.
I
stole my fucking weed.
Nothing came up.
So,
um,
it was then the,
the integration came to finding out where I got my stuff.
Oh yeah.
And you know,
sold.
When in Japan,
if you throw everything to a foreign person,
they'll drop it.
They won't want to go fight someone in America.
I told him it was a student from Guam.
They asked me for a name and I said Tony,
I knew like three Tonys and Guam,
so keep it real Tony.
And,
and we had like two days of questioning.
I mean you can talk in interrogation for like eight hours straight.
Just interrogation and late,
like the third day they said,
so happened caught me off guard man.
And the asked me,
what's Tony's last name and this fricking ridiculous.
A first name that popped the males Montana.
Read what?
I said.
That's a real one.
I said,
Montana,
I'll see those whole fuck if these guys watch scarf.
Honestly I'm screwed.
You know what?
I'm screwed.
Because they will start the integration all over if I get caught in a lie.
Right,
right,
right.
So he just,
I saw him write it down in Japanese in Montana and then he just started on and I
was like,
Huh,
hello Scarface.
Scarface get translated into Japanese.
Not that popular.
I don't think it's that popular there.
Yeah,
but
that's fucking hilarious.
Toni.
One time they gave me my marijuana,
you know.
How long was your worth,
the trip?
How long was your,
how long was the old or deal from him from
getting arrested to getting cleared?
28 days.
Which isn't a big deal if you know what's going to be 28 days,
but you're sitting there and you don't know what's going to happen to you and
you don't know what's going on in the outside world cause you're shut off and
you're wondering if you're going to spend five years.
It's kind of a 20 days is a long,
28 days.
Wow.
So you went from there and you said,
fuck it,
I'm going to,
I'm going to take on another fight.
He went there and it was good for me actually.
I mean I always think back and think,
okay,
I should have done this.
I should've done this.
If I didn't put the roast,
Jeanette.
And I keep thinking that and I catch myself and say,
wait a minute,
this is a probably one of the best things that happened to you.
Cause the big,
biggest thing that happened to be in that was I,
uh,
I learned how important it,
my freedom was.
I mean everyone takes it for granted every day.
Wake up,
well,
what are you going to do today?
And this like,
shit,
I got nothing to do.
His fricking overcast,
the shitty day.
What am I going to do it so hard.
Damn,
I miss this.
It's a Shitty Day,
you know?
But man,
just the fact that you can choose to stay at home,
you can choose to eat McDonald's or you can choose to just hang out or you can
choose to be bored,
you know,
freedom.
That's freedom's awesome.
So it was something that really made me realize how far important freedom was.
Yeah.
A lot of people take it for granted.
You know,
you dealing with a situation like that,
especially over something like we'd where it's so nonsensical and crazy,
they could take away your freedom for fucking years.
Yeah.
The thing about that is a,
a man I serve the time,
um,
went to the court.
We,
I got three years probation where I couldn't leave Japan for three years.
You didn't even get to go to my grandma's funeral.
And I figured,
okay,
I gotta I gotta be good this three years and then we'll start up again.
And then next thing I know I get a letter from the,
um,
the immigration telling me that I,
I just lost my green card,
cause of infringement and I got to leave Japan.
Whoa.
And I'm like,
well,
wait a minute.
I've been here for 20 years.
My whole life is here.
I bought a house there,
I got Jim's here,
I can leave Japan.
So I called them up and they had this like this real generic answer.
Okay,
if you're contesting it,
you were going to start an investigation,
you have to come down to immigration center and blah,
blah,
blah.
Went down,
took it.
It was an eight month investigation.
I mean it was ridiculous.
I mean,
I have to go down there numerous times and just like all day interrogations and
it would start from the beginning,
the name of your mom and dad.
What do they do?
I'm they clipped the fuck.
Does that have to do in anything?
You know,
and I'm just going along with the Roy and it's like the next week I go in for
another interrogation to start all over again to a whole new investigator.
I'm like,
what the fuck's going on?
I just told the other guy,
you know,
and they got to a point,
it was so bad that I got so frustrated in her as much as I needed to be in
Japan.
I looked at the guy said,
you know what,
I love Japan.
I made this place my home and it fucking Japan doesn't want me.
I don't want to fucking be here.
I told him straight up like that and was like,
I started them off.
Should I just screwed myself,
man,
boy,
I thought,
you know,
that's so frustrating.
And so,
you know,
if you,
I served my time man and I'm,
and I'm trying to do,
I'm doing good things for Japan,
you know,
and you guys got to try and kick me out if you guys don't want me,
you know what?
I don't want to fucking beer for them.
They don't want me here,
you know?
So you know,
they've interrogation went on and there was one guy that was a phantom way when
he was interrogating me and then he,
he,
he kind of did something illegal where he,
he told me that the,
between these two red markers said,
look at those two triggers.
You sit.
And he flipped it open.
He said,
this is our petitions coming in for you not to get kicked out of Japan.
And I saw the papers like this thick.
I was like,
well shit,
that's a lot.
He said,
yeah,
you got like 4,000 in already and the petitioners,
your parent isn't just names,
you got to live your name,
your phone number,
your address and everything and they'll see your ad.
It's not a bullshit where you can just get people to sign their names,
just write some.
So they're writing this 4,000 and every time we get an integration,
I see that,
that,
that between those two red markers is getting thicker and thicker,
and I come through fine at the end,
it came out to be 9,008 months,
9,000 people sent in that they don't want me to keep those Japan and immigration
is dear to protect Japan from dangerous,
so-called dangerous foreigners.
So when they're,
there are people that they're supposed to be protecting,
is sending in 9,000 letters saying they don't want this guy kicked out.
So that was the overwhelming thing that I could've been the boarded.
Yeah.
[inaudible].